You've just seen some pictures of Macintosh.
Now, I'd like to show you Macintosh in person.
I think the way out is not to slash and burn, it's to innovate.
That's how Apple got to its glory and I think that's how Apple could return to it.
There it is right there.
This amazing little device holds 1,000 songs.
Today, Apple is going to reinvent the phone.
The iPad, Macbook Air.
One is very fortunate if you get to work on just one of these in your career.
Apple has been very fortunate.
It's been able to introduce a few of these into the world.
I think if you do something and it turns out pretty good, then...
...you should go do something else wonderful.
Not dwell on it for too long, just figure out what's next.
It's a lot of hard work and it's a lot of worrying constantly.
And if you don't love it, you're gonna fail.
So you gotta love it, you gotta have passion.
We're gonna take the heat 'cause we wanna make the best product in the world for customers.
We're gonna instead focus our energy on these technologies,...
...which we think are in their ascendancy and we think we're gonna be...
...the right technologies for customers.
And you know what,...
...they're paying us to make those choices.
That's what a lot of customers pay us to do.
Don't be trapped by dogma, which is living with the results of other people's thinking.
Don't let the noise of others' opinions drown out your own inner voice.
And most important, have the courage to follow your heart and intuition.
They somehow already know what you truly want to become.
Everything else is secondary.